bienvenue dans les studios du Parlement
européen à Strasbourg à l'heure où la
France manifeste sur la réforme des
retraites nous allons nous pencher sur
ce dossier dans les différents pays
européens reconnus sont le d'entrer avec
un âge légal de départ à 62 ans la
France fait en fait figure d'exception
au sein des 27 entre le vieillissement
de la population le déclin des
naissances la quasi-totalité des États
membres ont prolongé le travail des
seniors jusqu'à 65 ans voire au-delà
mais cela soulève un certain nombre de
questions quel régime de retraite quel
montant pour les pensions et quel
employabilité aussi des plus âgés pour
en débattre un 2 euros députés sur notre
plateau Margarita marquez bonjour vous
êtes socialiste et démocrate portugaise
et dans votre pays pour partir avec une
pension complète et bien il faut voir
plus de 66 ans 66 ans et 7 mois
exactement et face à vous Sylvie Brunet
une ancienne DRH indirectrice des
ressources humaines eurodéputées
françaises renoue du groupe du du coup
le parti soutien d'Emmanuel Macron qui
tente d'imposer aux Français de
travailler plus longtemps alors avant de
donner à part la Slovaquie on le disait
la Suède 62 ans qui qui a un régime en
plus particulier la France est
championne européenne des jeunes
retraités plutôt aisés et pourtant on a
d'un certain point de vue la démographie
la plus vigoureuse d'Europe pourquoi on
continuerait pas à se régime finalement
écoutez il y a une constante dans toute
l'Europe c'est le vieillissement de la
population la meilleure espérance de vie
d'ailleurs dans le monde c'est le
continent européen qui est en tête et
donc à partir du moment on est dans un
système de retraite par répartition
c'est à dire que les actifs en gros
paient pour les retraités
et on reste plus longtemps à la retraite
il faut que le système soit viable ce
qui compte c'est que dans le futur on
puisse continuer à payer les retraites
on fait des bébés mais vous avez
peut-être remarqué les derniers chiffres
montrent un petit peu moins quand même
aussi en baisse sur ce sujet malgré
natalité qui est pas trop mal par
rapport aux chiffres dans l'Union
européenne ça n'est pas suffisant et
donc le système n'est pas à l'équilibre
l'État continue année à abonder pour le
maintenir à l'équilibre mais ça n'est
pas viable dans le futur c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre malheureusement c'est la
réalité elle est incontestable vous
venez de prononcer un mot intéressant
parce que finalement dans certains pays
une demi-douzaine la Pologne l'Autriche
la République tchèque on fait une clair
distinction entre les hommes et les
femmes les femmes ayant généralement le
droit de partir à la retraite plus tôt
vers 60 ans est-ce que pour vous cette
ce traitement différencié et just
comment vous l'expliquez on peut tout à
fait l'expliquer parce qu'on aborde des
régimes différents en France par exemple
par enfant on a des trimestres en plus
ce qui fait qu'on peut partir du coup
plutôt à partir du moment où on a
effectivement 8 trimestres pour être
clair par enfant voilà d'autres pays je
pense qu'ils ont adopté ce système là
parce qu'on sait que la maternité de
manière générale
interrompt les carrières et retarde
d'autant plus le départ à la retraite et
surtout souvent un petit qu'on a une
retraite basse c'est le problème des
femmes qui en moyenne ont une retraite
quand même plus basse en termes de
niveau que que les hommes et c'est
d'ailleurs un des objectifs de la
réforme dont personne ne parle en France
qui est de mettre un minimum de 1200
euros donc on en parle aussi oui quand
même enfin ça dépend qui mais de la part
des syndicats il faut juste on en parle
moins là il y a peut-être un problème
aussi de négociation de façon de faire
en effet malgré la Marquette disait que
les 66 ans et 7 mois au Portugal étaient
passés sans problème parce qu'il y avait
une forte consultation avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est là où
peut-être en France on n'y arrive pas et
on échoue côté je suis au modèle parti
politique français mon Président
François Bayrou l'a dit et on l'a fait
on a dit il faut un peu plus de temps de
temps de consultation négociation on a
eu trois mois quatre mois de plus et
c'est une bonne chose bon même si
fondamentalement il y a encore des des
oppositions il y a quand même une
négociation en cours qui est importante
sur les seniors en France le taux
d'emploi des seniors c'est 54% la
moyenne européenne c'est 60% donc les
seniors sont au chômage faut dire la
vérité donc vous vous demandez de
travailler plus longtemps à des gens qui
vont qui vont tomber dans le chômage
avoir une retraite moins forte c'est
pour ça qu'il faut qu'on traite le sujet
et là on est d'accord avec les organes
sources syndicales quand un rôle majeur
a joué sur le sujet parce que c'est eux
qui avons aussi dans les entreprises et
qui savent ce qui se passe secteur par
secteur et donc là je pense qu'il faut
continuer vraiment à travailler sur ce
sujet avec peut-être un peu plus
d'innovations sociales moi je suis une
ancienne DRH peut-être tous les fans de
carrière pour certains on veut plutôt
une retraite à temps partiel mais qui
quand même compenser on a peut-être pas
envie de travailler au même prix rythme
on a ce sujet c'est vrai en France
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que ce que
vous venez en tout petit détail moi je
me rappelle une question dont il faut
parler c'est la question des retraités
pauvres en Allemagne on sait qu'il y a 3
millions de retraités pauvres on a un
million en France il y en a quand même
beaucoup moins même s'il y en a trop
avec l'élévation de cet légal de départ
à la retraite est-ce que finalement les
gens n'iront pas forcément jusqu'au bout
parce que trop fatigué et partiront avec
une retraite qui n'est pas à taux plein
est-ce que est-ce que vous ne craignez
pas la précarisation des retraités
français je le comprends et j'en viens à
un autre sujet qui est majeur enfin de
mon point de vue il y a le sujet senior
une fois qu'on a parlé de l'âge il faut
pas focaliser que sur l'âge de départ
l'autre sujet majeur c'est la pénibilité
bien évidemment qu'en fonction du métier
que vous avez vous avez travaillé dans
le bâtiment moi j'étais des rage dans le
secteur de la propreté les gens ils sont
usés à 60 ans donc c'est un élément
qu'on doit prendre en considération
en leur permettant de partir plus tôt en
leur permettant d'avoir des bilans de
santé au fur et à mesure de pouvoir
peut-être changer ou si de métier quand
on le peut danser
c'est très compliqué on peut pas traiter
tout le monde de la même manière vous
êtes cadre dans les métiers bon
d'ailleurs en politique on est souvent
âgé je remarque on part pas mal de chez
les cadres aussi ancienne DRH vous avez
aussi je le sais mais parce que pas
c'est des questions de RH d'organisation
souvent même de sens du travail qu'on
mène qu'on a on a toutes ces questions
en ce moment qui qui se bousculent le
rôle du télétravail on se rend tout a
changé depuis le covid aussi ça peut
coûter en passant mais il faut voilà il
faut le prendre en considération cette
facteur de délimité pour répondre à
votre question sur les
d'ailleurs il y a le sujet des
travailleurs pauvres aussi et donc c'est
pour ça que ce que l'on veut d'où tout
nos travaux au passage au Parlement
européen salaire minimum on y est arrivé
un quatre pour le salaire minimum
les travaux en cours sur la transparence
des salaires on a fini pour les femmes
pour qu'ils puissent ces écarts de
salaire entre les femmes et hommes et
aussi les travailleurs des peu-formes
Numériques même si c'est un autre sujet
on va bientôt voter tout ça compte vous
vouliez réagir madame marquez pour
conclure on se dirige en Europe vers des
retraites de plus en plus tardives après
cette tuée à la tâche on va mourir au
travail c'est ça le projet de vie non
c'est pas le projet de vie ma collègue
vient de le dire vous savez aussi c'est
très individuel il y a des personnes qui
ne se supportent pas en s'arrêtant le
travail a aussi un rôle social des
retraités en France sont des bénévoles
actif c'est aussi un tissu social très
fort donc c'est formidable d'ailleurs
c'est on ne peut que s'en féliciter donc
c'est très dépendant de ça et vous savez
le vrai gros sujet pour ces travaux dit
pénibles ou on n'arrivait puiser à la
retraite c'est le sujet aussi des
conditions de travail c'est ça qu'il
faut adresser on a des conditions de
travail voilà améliorer sur les portes
charge lourdes sur les risques
psychosociaux j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur cette histoire de risque
psychosociaux les problématiques de
Bernard ça se travaille avant et si vous
êtes bien dans votre travail vous allez
peut-être partir plus tard à la retraite
mais vous vous êtes en bonne santé c'est
la santé qui compte qu'il faudra aussi
une réforme du travail